If you're interested in becoming
an investor, what are things to do or
what are things to think about?
And the first thing I tell people is
to get out Excel and do the math.
Knowing that if 19 out of 20
companies are going to fail and
you're going to invest
a certain amount of money.
One, how many companies
do you need to invest in?
If 19 of 20 are going to fail,
investing in one company is
not going to help you out.
The other thing is,
how much do you have to spread your bet?
And then,
what kind of returns do you need to see?
And it is very enlightening,
in particular, actually even if you're
an entrepreneur, doing that
math is incredibly insightful.
Because then when you're
talking to the investor,
you're kind of seeing it from
the other side of the table.
And they're seeing how
they're evaluating your idea.